à bruyères près d'epinal cinq semaines
après l'assassinât du petit grégory
l'instruction piétiné le climat reste
bien lourd jeudi dernier le juge
d'instruction interroge est une nouvelle
fois entre autre témoin la mère de
l'enfant
dénonçant les soupçons dont elle se sent
l'objet et le décide maintenant de
parler par rapport à la confrontation
qui a eu j'ai eu dix dirait que tout ce
que j'ai racontée au début ils préfèrent
la rigolade tout est dit que c'est pas
un prix que par rapport aux quatre
témoignages qui a eu lui dis que moi
maintenant je m'en puisque j'ai dû
avancer la vérité je suis pas là la
poste mardi sur l'île d'haïti
qu'est ce que vous pensez donc du
témoignage de quatre de nos collègues de
travail dont trois sont formels et qui
assure en avoir vu le mardi 1e hausse
moi je veux pas dire qu'elles mentent
mais je pense qu'elle se trompe puisque
pendant quinze jours à voir que le petit
soit enlevé il était malade il était
chez ma mère donc je prenais tous les
jours la route par ici par brouillet
donc je pense qu'elle se trompe d'une
journée end of mélanger j'aime bien
passé le mardi à l'évent je vous ai
quand vous étiez en train de changer le
chercher oui oui comment vous
personnellement vous réagissez au fait
qu'on puisse vous soupçonnez par combien
quand même jusqu'à c'est quand même mon
petit comme dans le mythe mais
finalement c'est quand même vous la
victime on avait l'impression qu'on
essaie un peu de semaines trouble dans
l'enclavé mais parce que le petit et
plus léger plus rien j'ai parce que sa
mort est rapportée d'avoir fait ça